let's compare nine point nine seven to
nine point naught to nine point seven
nine eight so to compare to figure out
which one of these is greater I like to
start with the largest place values and
then and then keep moving to smaller and
smaller ones until we actually see a
difference so they both have nine ones
so they both have nine ones so at least
in the ones place they seem comparable
to each other now let's go to the tenths
place so this number on the left has a
nine in the tenths place well the number
on the right has a seven in the tenths
place so right now we could view this
let's just write the whole numbers out
so this one is nine plus nine tenths we
haven't gone to the hundredths place yet
so far out of the two digits the two
places we've looked at this one on the
right this one on the right is nine plus
seven tenths plus seven plus seven
tenths so this immediately cused to me
that this the one on the left is a
larger number you're like hey how do I
know immediately that's the larger
number I have all this other stuff to
the right I have this nine eight to the
right I have the seven to the right and
the way to think about it is no matter
what you have even if you if you really
increase this right hand side here as
much as much as possible
you're still less than nine point eight
in fact if you keep incrementing the
thousands here you go from nine point
seven nine eight to nine point seven
nine nine to nine point eight so you
would have to actually increase to get
to even nine point eight and this is at
nine point nine so you can really just
look at the discrepancy in the largest
place value to recognize which number is
greater this has nine tenths this has
seven tenths it doesn't matter what's
going on in the hundreds and the
thousands place and to make that clear
let's actually add up these numbers and
compare them as fractions so let's keep
on going with this so you have seven
hundredths here so you have seven
hundredths here and here you have nine
hundredths so here you have nine
hundredths and then finally here you
have zero thousandths thousandths
and here let me do that in a different
color I use I already used blue and here
you have eight thousandths so plus eight
over a thousand so let's let's put
everything in terms of thousandths so
that we can add these all up and have
fractions both or have two fractions
over a thousandth or things in terms of
thousands so nine is the same thing as
nine thousand over a thousand nine
tenths well let's see if you multiplied
it by 10 you would get 90 over a hundred
multiplied by ten again you get nine
hundred thousandths seven hundredths
multiplied by 10 is 70 thousandths and
let's do that over here once again nine
is nine thousand over a thousand and
then plus seven hundred over a thousand
plus seven hundred over a thousand plus
ninety over a thousand plus 90 over a
thousand just multiply the numerator and
denominator by ten plus eight over a
thousand plus eight over a thousand and
so what is this number on the left this
number on the left is how many
thousandths is it it's nine thousand
nine hundred and seven sorry nine
thousand nine hundred seventy so it's
nine thousand nine thousand nine hundred
nine hundred and seventy and seventy
thousands while this number on the right
here is the number on the right here is
nine thousand nine thousand seven
hundred seven hundred ninety eight
ninety eight thousands so here once
again you're comparing two numbers they
have the same number of thousands this
has nine hundred this only has seven
hundred so even though this is almost
eight hundred eight hundred is still
less than nine hundred so no matter how
you think about it the number on the
left the number on the left is greater
than the number
on the right